thank you mr chief justice i'd like to
just make three points in rebuttal and
i'd like to begin with the point that i
understood general stone to be making
that if this court ultimately concludes
and whole women's health that the
providers can sue that the authority
we're claiming here to sue as well is
extraordinary or unprecedented and i
think it is important to recognize that
when the united states of america filed
this suit to try to redress the harm to
the supremacy of federal law in texas
the whole women's health providers had
not been able to obtain any effective
redress from the courts the law had been
permitted to take effect and it had
immediately had its intended operation
of chilling the exercise of
constitutionally protected conduct
altogether so that abortions that are
protected under roe and casey after six
weeks of pregnancy could not occur at
all and i think that that shows the
threat to the supremacy that comes from
this attempted design of a law to block
access to the judiciary it may well be
and i hope that this court holds in
whole woman's health that the providers
can move forward but that hasn't stopped
the harm to the sovereign interests of
the united states in the meantime as
texas has succeeded while these novel
issues worked their way through the
courts in blocking access to care that
is protected under this court's
precedence
and that leads me to my second point
which is to emphasize the nature of the
sovereign interest here it is in
preventing a state from being able to
act in direct defiance of this court's
precedence and block access to the
judicial review that congress and this
court have deemed necessary to vindicate
federal rights and to further make it
the state court mechanism that might
provide some alternative basis for
raising those constitutional claims
wholly ineffective and unavailable
the final point is to just step back for
a moment and and think about the
startling implications of texas's
argument here
across the arguments this morning texas
position is that no one can sue not the
women whose rights are most directly
affected
not the providers who have been chilled
in being able to provide those women
with care and not the united states in
this suit they say that federal courts
just have no authority under existing
law to provide any mechanism to redress
that harm and if that is true if the
state can just take this simple
mechanism of taking its enforcement
authority and giving it to the general
public backed up with a bounty of ten
thousand dollars or one million dollars
if they can do that then no
constitutional right is safe
no constitutional decision from this
court is safe
that would be an intolerable state of
affairs and it cannot be the law our
constitutional guarantees cannot be that
fragile and the supremacy of federal law
cannot be that easily subject to
manipulation
so we would ask this court to hold that
the united states can proceed with this
action and affirm the preliminary
injunction entered by the district court
and immediately vacate the stay that the
fifth circuit entered in this case so
that texas cannot continue to deny women
in its borders a right protected by this
court's precedence one day longer
thank you council the case is submitted
honorable court is now adjourned until
tomorrow at 10 o'clock
okay so there's the the arguments um
of the
of the
case you had another chance to see the
supreme court oral arguments on the
texas support
so uh you can go back and re-watch in
the stream i had uh it's about an hour
and a half of these arguments um you
heard there at the end that the
uh the united states solicitor
general who is making the case for the
united states in that they're trying to
get a an injunction against this uh sb8
um again i'm not an attorney we need to
turn to like uh
ben mizellis and michael popock on legal
af and i'm sure that uh this weekend uh
they'll give us more updates
from um this this hearing that they had
today these
oral arguments but at the end there you
heard that the united states solicitor
general who is making the case um to get
an injunction on this sb8 which they
already have they're just trying to get
the stay on it from the district court
but uh
there that that is what
they're trying to get um let me bring up
sorry just trying to get the
get twitter open so we can do some
surfing surf and surf and surf and
twitter um
but anyways the united states solicitor
general is making the case that hey
hey by the way
by the way
um
if this if this is allowed to stand on
this particular right and this
particular liberty
that americans have it can be applied to
any of them
so what's to stop any state from
basically giving away the right to
enforce any laws to the citizenry in a
vigilante style
type in law enforcement where it's
enforced with bounties like in the uh
the sba texas abortion bounty law it's
ten thousand dollars
um so
again if you apply it to other laws like
um you know the second amendment the
first amendment um these different
things
you you can shed as a state
a particular state that is controlled by
either party
can shed any rights that they would like
to shed away
from
their citizenry like
let's just take a blue state for example
that has democratic control if this law
is allowed to stand
then in blue states it is
if if the court lets this law stand it
is theoretically possible that a blue
state could basically hand over their
authority
to the second amendment
and they could uh enlist vigilantes to
enforce the law in that state whatever
those laws may be
and they could uh you know
get a bounty system
or a bounty type
vigilante system that they have on sb8
and that could become
the way to enforce
the quote-unquote
law or
gun law or you know what whatever that
whatever the case may be that that state
wants to do
but in sbh case
the craziest part is that it just shows
that the gqp
doesn't really care about liberties they
care about
making sure that women don't have
liberties
that's their direct aim here and to take
the liberty away from um a woman's
the liberty for her to make a choice on
her body
um now
they they kind of made the case that oh
well i mean they have the ability within
the first six weeks
while most women don't even know they're
pregnant within the first six weeks
and that's intentional here that's
intentional and that's what the united
states solicitor general and the
the lawyer for the citizens of texas
also argued so
if you want to go back and watch that it
is uh
again when you're listening to
uh the scotus on c-span the supreme
court united states on c-span
it is very very heavy in legal jargon so
uh that's why we need to look to shows
like legal af um
i i watch legal afr listen to legal af
uh
every weekend
because uh ben and popak really break
down
some of these issues into simple terms
as opposed to
you know trying to figure out exactly
what all these legal things mean
in the terms and how it works um they
did a really good job this week
explaining the written how written
housing written how the kyle
rittenhausen case
um and the the words of victim now
i i am i am of the exact opposite uh
belief that i don't care what the legal
argument is
when you murder someone they are a
victim of murder when you're charged
with murder they should be called
victims of murder that's how it should
be
uh you know that
especially in the case of the vigilante
kyle rittenhouse
so but they they do a good job of
explaining the non-bias
uh non-either side or
of that judge's decision and i'm sure
they'll do a good job of
explaining what happened in this hearing
that was a couple hours long
to give us
a good update of
exactly what happened and what
everything that they said means what it
means to
the citizenry and democracy because
really this case
is about liberty women's liberty women's
rights and democracy and where they
where women and women's rights stand in
our democracy but it's a slippery slope
this could be applied to other
to other rights i mean um
you know
other rights that is granted to us by
the constitution
but this case in particular is about the
gqp hating women
and that's what
they they they're anti-woman
is what they are
they're anti-woman and the pro-life
movement the pro-lifers in this country
have never gone this far
they've always had this plan in their
back pocket i mean there's always been
this hint
of this sb-8 style
state vigilante where they they have a
lupo loophole in the law and try to
circumvent
um the united states constitution
because that's ultimately what they they
they also hate is the constitution
because the constitution grants you
rights rights that they don't want you
to have
i mean they want them they want those
rights i mean you've seen you've seen
the my body my choice morons with this
vaccine
in new york where there's a ton of
firefighters and a ton of police
officers that are unwilling and nurses
unwilling to get
the vaccine by the specific date which
was today
and [ __ ] them [ __ ] them you don't i the
way i see it you've had a [ __ ] almost a
whole [ __ ] year to get this thing
they want a couple weeks get the [ __ ]
out of here a couple weeks well you had
you had [ __ ] you had six weeks
since they announced it where the [ __ ]
were those weeks go get it or don't have
a job that [ __ ] them [ __ ] them [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them oh well it'll make unsafe and
there won't be as many firefighters oh
trust me there will people who want to
be firefighters in the place of those
people this is this is the boneheaded
[ __ ] this is the stupid boneheaded [ __ ]
that we always go through this is like
this labor late keep calling it a labor
shortage it's not a labor shortage
there's a labor demand
you [ __ ] boneheads there's a labor
demand and when that happens when that
happens and employers aren't paying
enough for the demand
they have [ __ ] vacant spots and now
hiring spots there's not a labor
shortage there's a labor demand guess
who's that is good for workers
so [ __ ] those goddamn police officers
that got this all twisted around that
they're being forced to have the vaccine
you're not being forced you just don't
get to be a [ __ ] firefighter or cop
or a nurse you're making that choice
that's the choice you're making
to act like women in texas
for whatever reason
needing to make a choice about their
pregnancy
that there's no consequences
to that choice is [ __ ] boneheaded
that is the dumbest [ __ ] thing i've
ever heard of that that that somehow
having to make a choice about your
pregnancy and your uterus has no
consequences
it is it it is no wonder women are so
[ __ ] fed up of men telling them what
the [ __ ] to do and what laws we should
have about their bodies
you [ __ ] idiots
the [ __ ] are you talking about
acting like there's no consequences
none whatsoever to a woman making a
choice about her pregnancy and her
uterus and her body that there's no
consequences that the consequences are
all on their neighbor of being offended
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you hey guess what you don't want
to get the jab you don't have a job as a
uh
a new york
firefighter
and your neighbor gets to be offended by
that but they don't get to sue you
they don't get to sue you
you get to make that choice you can stay
at home and sit your ass there and not
have a job and your neighbor has to be
okay with that they can be offended but
they can't see you for ten thousand
dollars think about that that's what
we're talking about here in texas
a woman has to make a choice based on
her pregnancy and her life and her body
and her family
and someone can can sue her for ten
thousand dollars if she makes a certain
choice
just like in in new york city where
these firefighters are making the choice
not to get vaccinated and they get to
set it home because they don't have
their jobs
it would be like their neighbor being
able to sue them because they don't have
their jobs and they didn't get
vaccinated
well that ain't if that ain't a thing we
should do
we shouldn't have vigilante law
enforcement that's the dumbest [ __ ]
thing i've ever heard in my life that's
not a democracy that's not
so hopefully the k the case was made but
it is obvious
more than ever it is obvious that this
gqp gerrymanders supreme court
they want to strike down roe v wade now
rather this is the case they do it on or
not
i don't know i don't think so
because roberts is going to have to
gather up some votes here
to to save this country from vigilante
justice here
but it is it is very clear very clear
from the questions
and the aim of the argument
from the court that is the justices
that
the gqp gerrymandered justices
barrett
kavanagh
gorsuch
thomas
you [ __ ]
alito you [ __ ]
their direction
is to to tear down roe v wade they do
not want women to have liberty over
their bodies they don't
want
it it's enough of this [ __ ] we need to
readjust this court
and that's why you got to go vote you
got to go vote tomorrow in virginia if
you're in virginia and you're registered
to vote go vote vote vote vote and you
have to vote for terry mcauliffe you
have to vote for terry mcauliffe because
if not we're going to get more of this
gqp janu mer
gerrymander court type [ __ ]
in virginia you want virginia to turn
into trumpism
that's what we got on the court today
is trumpism
these [ __ ] trump humping fools
sitting up there making these arguments
against citizens of texas
losing their liberty because of
vigilante justice
because a bunch of texas taliban doesn't
like women
and doesn't want women to have rights
or their liberty over their utes
uteruses or their bodies
let's get our [ __ ] [ __ ] together here
people and let's go vote these
[ __ ] out
it's about time
okay let's go surfing who wants to surf
who
wants to surf
who wants to serve sorry for not surfing
let's go um